16 aproximadamente han transcurrido
desde el comienzo de la invasión rusa de
Ucrania 16 meses 16 meses desde que
prácticamente un desconocido volado y
mirtelevski se convirtió en uno de los
principales protagonistas de la
actualidad internacional el presidente
de Ucrania es ya todo un símbolo de la
resistencia de su país ante los ataques
del kremlin estos han sido 16 meses en
los que el propio zelensky se ha
dedicado a pedir ayuda por activa y por
pasiva de hecho es algo que todos
sabemos una de las claves que explican
la admirable resistencia de Ucrania ha
sido precisamente el constante
suministro de equipos militares por
parte de occidente Pues bien en mayo que
dio un paso más hacia la última de sus
grandes peticiones fijaos te doy la
bienvenida a la decisión histórica de
Estados Unidos y su presidente de apoyar
una coalición internacional de aviones
de combate esto mejorará enormemente
nuestro ejército en el cielo cuento con
discutir la implementación práctica de
esta decisión en la Cumbre del g7 en
Hiroshima coalición internacional de
aviones de combate lleva pidiendo los
desde el comienzo de la invasión ya que
la fuerza aérea de Ucrania es muy
limitada de herencias soviética es
además muy escasa el número de aviones
hasta el momento la aportación de
occidente se ha limitado a unos 30.000
29 procedentes de Polonia y Eslovaquia
importantes pero totalmente
insuficientes a juicio de gif Por eso
zelenski siempre ha insistido en que lo
que necesitan lo que necesitan de verdad
son los f-16 de fabricación
estadounidense pero lo cierto Es que
biden mostró mucha reticencias a
suministrarlos sin embargo queridos
amigos ahora algo ha cambiado
[Música]
a finales del mes de mayo en Hiroshima
en la Cumbre del g7 el presidente de
Estados Unidos dio por fin buenas
noticias al presidente ucraniano
hasta ahora occidente consideraba que
Ucrania no necesitaba aviones de combate
para defenderse de Rusia ahora sin
embargo han cambiado de opinión Claro
que esperad un momento porque los f-16
no van a llegar de un día para otro hay
muchas cuestiones que aún están nunca
Mejor dicho en el aire cuestiones cuya
resolución requerida de por lo menos
unos cuantos meses Así que la pregunta
es cómo ha sido el desempeño de las
fuerzas aéreas de Ucrania hasta el
momento qué cambio puede suponer
realmente en el curso de la guerra que
Kid disponga de un avión de combate como
el f-16 de dónde saldrían los f-16
destinados a Ucrania queridos amigos hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes antes tenemos que ver dónde
comenzó todo atentos
me estoy quedando sin Sams Tío Sam
hasta el momento la Guerra de Ucrania
puede dividirse en cuatro fases la
primera se corresponde con los dos
primeros meses mucho recordaréis como al
principio Rusia se lanzó rápidamente
sobre kit para acabarlo antes posible
con el gobierno de zelensky El kremelín
fracasó sin embargo Tuvo más éxito en el
sur y en el este de Ucrania donde sus
tropas sí que lograron protagonizar
importantes avances Claro que lo que nos
importa en este vídeo Es que la Aviación
rusa se dedicó en las primeras horas de
la guerra a bombardear las principales
defensas de Ucrania contra los ataques
aéreos hablamos de infraestructuras como
los radares o algunos aeródromos por
fortuna por aquí en esta ocasión la
inteligencia de Estados Unidos hizo
bastante bien su trabajo e informó
colorante antelación del ataque ruso eso
le permitió ucranear y expresar sus
equipos y así minimizar los daños fue
una jugada absolutamente decisiva ya que
así pudieron salvar de los primeros
ataques rusos aviones helicópteros y
drones armados que luego utilizarían
para atacar las columnas rusas que
avanzaban confiadas hacia aquí la tan
esperada superioridad del ejército ruso
no se materializó sobre el terreno Y
para sorpresa de casi todos tampoco en
el aire Porque queridos amigos amigas
adentrarse en los cielos ucranianos
conlleva riesgos añadidos para los rusos
fijaos
la defensa aérea era clave para las
fuerzas armadas soviéticas esto
significa que tanto Rusia como Ucrania
heredaron sistemas de defensa aérea
grandes y fuertes de hecho Ucrania tenía
la segunda densidad más alta de este
tipo de sistemas de toda Europa
seguramente sólo superada por Rusia a
esto hay que añadir los manpats los
sistemas de defensa antiaérea portátil
como los sigla y los stinger que los
ucranianos han logrado tener en grandes
números todo ello causó pérdidas más que
significativas para la Fuerza Aérea rusa
hizo que de facto las hordas de Putin no
pudieran hacerse con el control pleno
del espacio aéreo
[Música]
así que ya lo veis Al comenzar la
invasión Rusia no logró acabar con las
defensas aéreas de Ucrania y eso eso
supuso un duro golpe para sus planes
posteriormente entre abril y agosto de
2022 El kreblín centros ofensiva en la
región del más y luego la tercera fase
de la guerra se inició con la
contraofensiva de Ucrania en el verano
del 22 entonces las tropas de kiev
lograron importantes avances hasta
noviembre con el apoyo precisamente de
su fuerza aérea la fuerza aérea que
Rusia no consiguió destruir esto supuso
que se reanudarán los escarceos entre
aviones de ambos bandos por su parte
Rusia aumentó sus ataques con misiles
sobre Ucrania sin embargo hasta la
actual contraofensivo ucraniana la
guerra estuvo completamente estancada
entre diciembre y junio de este año
durante esta cuarta fase de Rusia ha
seguido apostando por agotar con sus
misiles y drones los recursos de Ucrania
para la lucha antiaérea agotar los
llamados
Sam es un acrónimo que significa surface
to Air es decir misil tierra aire
Ucrania disponía de un auténtico arsenal
de Sams de la era soviética que ha ido
disminuyendo con el curso de la guerra y
aunque lleguen sistemas de defensa
antiaérea suministrados por occidente su
integración con el resto de equipos de
los que dispone Ucrania lleva tiempo
durante meses el presidente ucraniano
estuvo reclamando accidente lo mejor de
sus inventarios hablamos de equipos como
los tanques abrahams y los misiles
patrios uno de los sistemas de defensa
antiaérea más sofisticados del mundo no
tuvo éxito por un tiempo pero claro si
Volar Sobre Ucrania fuera digamos menos
peligroso entonces Rusia podría lograr
su tan deseada su prioridad aérea Y
entonces se sumarían prácticamente todas
las posibilidades de que Ucrania
reconquistara su territorio Así que he
llegado este momento como decimos en
visualpolitik fue dicho y hecho Estados
Unidos enviará a Ucrania sistemas de
misiles patrio y tanques más rápido de
lo planeado originalmente Pues bien ha
obtenido los abrams los leopards y los
Patriots en retomó otra de sus grandes
peticiones los cazas f-16
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ya os hemos contado que vaiden acaba de
dar luz verdea que empiece el
entrenamiento de los pilotos ucranianos
en este tipo de aviones sin embargo
amigos no hace tanto que el propio biden
negó que Ucrania necesitará f-16 Mirad
por ejemplo esta entrevista en ABC news
del pasado febrero del 2023
fijaos
y ahora más de uno estará pensando pero
vamos a ver Enrique si la Guerra de
Ucrania ha estado estancada durante
Tantos meses Qué día ha pasado para que
en apenas tres meses la Casa Blanca
cambie de opinión Pues bien El caso es
que a principios de abril se filtraron
unas informaciones del pentágono que
indicaban que el equilibrio en los
cielos de Ucrania estaba a punto de
romperse a favor de Rusia fijaos Ucrania
puede quedarse sin defensas aéreas en
mayo advierten documentos filtrados del
pentágono desde que empezaron a circular
este tipo de noticias en occidente hubo
de repente división de opiniones sobre
qué hacer al respecto algunos argumentan
que Ucrania lo que necesita son más
defensas aéreas del estilo de los
Patriot o los nasam equipos que desde
hace ya tiempo los países aliados le
están suministrando pero ahora también
ha crecido el número de los que creen
que es urgente proporcionar aviones de
combate y la pregunta es qué puede
significar exactamente la llegada de
f-16 a Ucrania Pues bien Ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Top Gun
acaba de comenzar el verano Y cranear
todavía no se ha quedado sin defensas
aéreas gracias a occidente pero la
presión rusa continúa y si los Sams los
misiles tierra aire se agotan Entonces
los aviones rusos tendrían vía libre
para bombardear Ucrania Incluso si Estas
armas comienzan a escasear el gobierno
de digamos que tendría que elegir entre
proteger las ciudades las
infraestructuras las bases militares o a
las tropas desplegadas en el frente en
teoría los aviones de combate pueden
sustituir a las defensas aéreas
terrestres para derribar aviones
enemigos drones y misiles de crucero eso
es de hecho lo que han estado haciendo
hasta ahora con sus aviones sin embargo
todo indica que Australia están
empezando a pasar factura los 16 meses
de conflicto al menos eso es lo que nos
dicen los datos ofrecidos por el general
estadounidense James Ucrania ha perdido
60 aviones y ha derribado 70 en la
invasión rusa según jeky amigos a priori
no puede pensar bueno no está mal No
tampoco parecen tantos aviones perdidos
y desde luego los ucranianos han
derribado más pero claro el problema es
que esos 60 aviones de bate perdidos son
Ni más ni menos que el 40% de la
aviación ucraniana de antes de la guerra
Ucrania solo le quedan alrededor de 80
aviones frente a los casi 500 que el
kremlin tiene asignados a este conflicto
es decir que la diferencia es de aupa y
espero hace un momento Porque además de
una abrumadora superioridad numérica la
Aviación rusa dispone también de mejores
radares y municiones con mayor alcance
ahora bien como han fracasado en
eliminar las defensas aéreas de Ucrania
los aviones rusos se ven obligados a
disparar misiles o lanzar bombas desde
una distancia bastante considerable lo
que por supuesto reduce muchos
efectividad y luego pues no olvidéis que
hablamos de armas rusas pero el kremlin
también está utilizando drones armados
muchos son los famosos ajed 136 iraníes
que están matando dos pájaros de un tiro
los aves de Ucrania y la capacidad
económica de afrontar la guerra fabricar
los drones iraníes cuesta tan solo
20.000 Dólares pero derribarlos se
dispara hasta los 500 mil dólares lo que
supone una preocupación creciente en
Ucrania según un informe esto por no
hablar de los patrios lanzar solo uno de
estos misiles puede costar hasta 4
millones de dólares un auténtico
pastizal vamos es que lanzar 40 patrios
puede llegar a equivaler a 160 millones
una locura como os podéis imaginar este
ritmo de Gastón no hay economía que lo
aguante salvo Claro está que se hace el
tío sama así que la opción de utilizar
cazas para neutralizar los ataques
aéreos parece bastante razonable pero el
problema de la fuerza aérea de Ucrania
es que se han quedado obsoletos gif
dispone de mix 29 y su coi 27 de la era
soviética y Polonia Eslovaquia le han
dado más 1029 Pero ha llegado el momento
estos aviones no tienen capacidad de
hacer frente a la Aviación rusa Ucrania
necesita una flota nueva y justo aquí es
donde cobra protagonismo el f-16 estamos
hablando Ni más ni menos que de la
columna vertebral de las fuerzas aéreas
de la otan Durante los últimos 40 años
su llegada al teatro de operaciones
complementaría las defensas antiaéreas
de Ucrania y les aportaría algo nuevo la
movilidad
[Música]
los cazas pueden proteger diferentes
objetivos al moverse rápidamente por una
área además debido a la curvatura de la
tierra los radares de los aviones pueden
ver objetos voladores a distancias más
largas que los radares terrestres una
ventaja a la que hay que Añadir que los
radares de los ap16 tienen mayor
capacidad que los de los cazas mig-29
[Música]
la formación de pilotos ucranianos para
pilotar los f-16 no será ningún problema
tiene más pilotos que aviones Así que ha
hecho una lista de hasta 50 pilotos que
ya están disponibles para comenzar a
entrenarse con este avión de esta forma
estos pilotos podrían estar preparados
en unos pocos meses y estar así
operativos antes de finales de año sin
embargo queridos amigos todavía Existen
algunas dudas una es que los f-16
necesitan pistas largas y lisas para
despegar y claro en el clemenín también
lo saben fijaos Rusia lanza un ataque
con misiles contra objetivos en los
aeródromos militares de Ucrania una
alternativa sería utilizar aeródromos
dispersos e improvisados estos podrían
ser más numerosos y más difíciles de
encontrar para los rusos pero claro Las
pistas serían también mucho más cortas y
rugosas o en otras palabras mucho más
peligrosas
Así que sí es cierto que Ucrania ahora
mismo puede tener un problema con las
pistas un argumento que refuerza a los
que defienden que lo que necesita
Ucrania es más artillería blindados y
Sams en lugar de cazas algunos también
temen que proporcionar el f-16 Ucrania
suponga una nueva escalada del conflicto
algo que en cualquier caso ha descartado
el propio biden que asegura que el f-16
sólo servirá para defender a Ucrania no
para atacar a Rusia
[Música]
a ver tengamos algo en cuenta hablamos
de un avión que está operativo desde el
año 1978 el mismo año en el que se
estrenaba gris en los cines Así que no
los f-16 no son precisamente el último
hito de la Aviación y no parece que eso
llega a Ucrania pudiera desatar el
Apocalipsis nuclear además la Casa
Blanca ha sido muy hábil al utilizar la
Cumbre del g7 para hacer estos anuncios
biden vinculó a sus aliados con esta
decisión y aquí es donde surge
precisamente la coalición internacional
de aviones de combate en que se va a
traducir pues atentos
[Música]
el escudo aéreo ucraniano
queridos amigos el impulso dado por
Estados Unidos a la coalición de aviones
de combate es decisivo en tanto en
cuanto se necesita lo que hay de
Washington para la exportación de
cualquier caza de f-16 a Ucrania Aunque
estos cazadas pertenezcan ahora a otros
países Así que la coalición agrupa a
varios países europeos y aunque aún no
tiene una denominación oficial teleskin
ha lanzado su prueba propuesta y Oye la
verdad Marvel no lo hubiera hecho mejor
la coalición de aviones de combate la
reunión con Los líderes de los países
europeos hablamos de temas relacionados
con el inicio de la formación de pilotos
ucranianos en f-16 y otros tipos de
aeronaves acordamos continuar trabajando
hacia una decisión oficial para crear la
coalición de aviones de combate ucranian
Sky shield por otro tipo de aeronaves El
esquí probablemente se refiere a los
gripes suecos Suecia dispone de
alrededor de un centenar de estos
aviones pero hasta que no entre
definitivamente en la otan no podrá
deshacerse de ninguno de ellos En cambio
se han construido más de 4.600 f16 desde
que diera comienzo su producción en los
años 70 algunos todavía se están
construyendo del sur y Estados Unidos
desde luego planea mantener operativos
dos décadas más sus modelos más nuevos
pero sin embargo hay países que tienen
pensado reemplazarlos en cuanto les
llegue los nuevos f-35 Así que
acostumbrados a noticias como esta es
probable que los Países Bajos envíen
f-16 a Ucrania después del entrenamiento
de pilotos Países Bajos es uno de los
principales impulsores del Ucrania
también Reino Unido pero no tiene f-16
una opción es que Londres Se los compre
a otros países y luego se los regala
Ucrania
sea como sea proporcionar f16 va a
suponer para los aliados un nuevo
esfuerzo económico bastante importante
para que os hagáis una idea estos son
los cálculos ofrecidos por colincal
subsecretario estadounidense de política
de defensa
luego también hay otros países europeos
que serán claves para el Ucrania en por
ejemplo todo indica que el mantenimiento
de los f-16 podría realizarse
inicialmente en Polonia y Rumanía países
fronterizos con Ucrania que ya utilizan
este tipo de cazas incluso Rumanía ha
cobrado un protagonismo especial las
últimas semanas Mirad occidente Mira a
Rumanía como posible lugar de
entrenamiento en f-16 para pilotos
ucranianos no hay que olvidar que tanto
Polonia como Rumanía son países miembros
de la otan que vayan a hacer en su
territorio el entrenamiento y sobre todo
el mantenimiento de los f-16 significa
que a priori permanecerán lejos del
alcance de los misiles rusos algo que
seguramente no agradará nada que nada El
crimen de momento Putin ya lanzado sus
habituales amenazas
[Música]
Aunque lo cierto queridos amigos es que
por ahora parece que Putin estará más
ocupado lidiando con pregosín y los
Wagner además quedan bastantes meses
para ver f-16 en Ucrania quizás ni
siquiera lleguen hasta 2024 veremos pero
desde luego enviar aviones de combate
lanza Rusia un serio mensaje sobre el
compromiso de occidente a largo plazo en
la defensa de Ucrania pero llegados
hasta aquí la pregunta es para ti
piensas que los f-16 serán decisivos
para derrotar a Rusia creéis que estos
cazas pueden provocar una nueva escala
del conflicto dejadnos vuestras
respuestas por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y hablamos debate y ahora si
este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle al botón de like y
suscribiros a visualpolitik si es que
aún no lo habéis hecho una vez más
Muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]